Andre has posted this tweet a while back
he says that with the many puzzle pieces
dropping recently we should consider
llms not as a chatbot but the kernel
process of a new operating system you
know it can orchestrate all of these
things and it can even act as all of
these things it can act as an operating
system it can orchestrate databases and
so on but I want to say Andre Andre an
operating system is nothing your
creativity limits you thinking inside a
box what we're doing here we go beyond
and we Implement an entire CPU in GPT so
I can run any program that I want I have
a compiler and I can run any program
that I want through that compiler and I
can then execute it against any language
model in the background let me show you
how this works I have a deal for you you
listen to me for 30 seconds to talk
about today's sponsor weights and biases
and by doing that I'm happy you're happy
weights and biases is Happy everyone's
happy if that sounds good to you then
here is the deal the course training and
fine-tuning large language models has
been created by weights and biases and
is completely free this is a free course
about well training and fine-tuning
large language models the lineup of
instructors they have as you can see
right here is sweet like these are
seriously good people and you might
recognize one or the other the current
machine learning landscape the course is
is done together with Mosaic and
contains 37 lessons now already said
it's about training and fine-tuning
large language models but the column
here in the middle is what I'm
personally most excited about curate the
data set and establish an evaluation
approach from practice and I happen to
be in more in Industry more in practice
now now I can tell you that yeah
fine-tuning is flashy impr prompting is
flashy but to even be able to measure
quality of something like a language
model especially one you've trained
yourself is among the most crucial and
among the most demanded uh skills there
are thanks to weights and biases for
sponsoring this video and let's go on
hello everyone look at this program
right here I'm going to run it it's
called fizzbuzz and it's often used in
programming interviews use the idea is
you iterate from a number from0 to 30 in
this case and every time the number is
divisible by three you output the word
Fizz every time it's divisible by five
you output the word buzz and every time
you output it's divisible by both you
output the word fbus otherwise you just
output the number and you can already
see there is an output we have an output
fizzbuzz now one one is the correct next
output because that's not divisible by
three or five and we hope we hope the
next output is going to be two um let's
wait and the excitement is palpable too
there it is and the only thing I wish
for now is a little bit of Fizz a little
bit of Fizz for the next
output fizz fizz there we go that's it
yo so you may think what's the matter
it's like the simplest C program ever
and I'm making a big deal about
so you know what is it let me show you
let me clear this and turn on debug
output all right so if I turn on debug
output a whole different picture appears
look at that look at that it's going
it's doing all of this is happening and
until you actually see a print output uh
there's going to be a long long time so
what you're seeing right here are fiz
bus there we go what you're seeing right
here are machine instructions getting
executed against a against a processor
usually the way a computer works is that
you have what's called code and code is
a set of instructions it's loaded into
memory so there are instructions and
there is a program counter that just
kind of runs through these instructions
and every code does something uh so you
have the central thing the CPU and the
CPU takes a piece of code and it's
supposed to do computations so it has
these things called Reg registers let's
call them buckets so these are registers
and it has memory and it has input
output and so on all of this available
so the CPU gets an instruction for
example uh move move some number from
register number four to register number
eight so what it will do is it'll take
it out into from register 4 and put it
into register 8 it can also do some
something like how about you compare so
that's a really interesting instruction
how about you compare CMP register 4 to
the value one okay and you store the
result in register 2 so it'll go to
register 4 it compare it with the value
one and it will store either a zero or a
one in register number two whatever that
is and then the next point the next uh
instruction here could be something like
branch Branch or conditional Branch um
depending on register 2 and if you know
if register 2 is true then go to
instruction number four otherwise go to
instruction number eight so we're here
we look at register number two and if
that is true right if before before this
was register 4 was equal to one we're
going to jump to one instruction
otherwise we're going to do jump to
another instruction instuction this is
how at the lowest level your computer
implements things like if conditions uh
you can do math here you can sum two
things together you can you know Jump
Around control flow loops and so on all
of this is implemented at the lowest
level by instructions to the CPU now
okay what does this have anything to do
with this and why is this video called I
built the most expensive CPU ever um you
might already guess what's coming right
now in fact all of the instructions that
you see right here they are in fact CPU
instructions and each one of them is
getting executed not by the actual CPU
in your system but by
GPT simulating a CPU so I can run any
program that I want I have a compiler
and I can run any program that I want
through that compiler and I can then
execute it against GP against any
language model in the background let me
show you how this works and this really
is the most expensive CPU ever it takes
hundreds of instructions just to get to
the first fizzbuzz and every time the an
instruction is executed I send a whole
bunch of stuff to GPT and I get an
answer back and that's one machine
instruction we've come full circle we've
built CPUs uh we have trained huge
language models on the
and now these language models can act as
CPUs so fundamentally when you write
computer code uh you at some point need
to make it into machine instructions
which means you need to compile it in
some way now granted languages like
Python and uh JavaScript they do a
different thing but if you write a c
program like this something has to take
it and compile it and that's usually a
compiler now what the compiler does the
parts you may know is it's going to turn
it into assembly code so GCC can do this
for you and if you look at the generated
assembly code you can see much more of
what's going on this here is FS buuz
compiled for the N x86 architecture and
you can see all the little operations
right here we first push some stuff we
add some stuff we push some stuff we
move some stuff and eventually we'll
compare some stuff and we'll jump around
depending on the results of those
comparisons we multiply things here
which uh certainly has something to do
with the fact that we're Computing
remainders of of multiplications and so
on of Divisions and all of this you
might be familiar with now if you're
using something like Mac OS uh like I'm
using right here the actual compiler you
may use isn't necessarily GCC um but a
compiler called clang cang I'm not
exactly sure how it does it now that has
a llvm tool chain in the background and
that essentially means llvm is a tool
chains for many many compilers not only
C but C++ any kind of uh language can
Implement an llvm pre-compiler let's say
to turn its program into llvm
instruction and then llvm can take care
of really outputting the assembly or the
machine code for a given architecture so
llvm is this unified thing and if we
look at that it's actually much more
readable so here is the llvm output the
llvm intermediate representation for fs
buuz and this looks like something one
can actually understand assembly still
has a lot of high registers low
registers and blah blah blah I don't
want to deal with any of that but this
here this seems doable so what do we
need to do in order to achieve our goal
of building a
GPT CPU first of all we need to parse
this program and I've done that so if
you look in the parsing file I've
written a parser to parse all of the
relevant instructions right here you can
see signed remainder addition you can
see right here Store Branch to labels
and so on so I've written a parer that
takes LM intermediate representation and
builds essentially a an abstract
representation of that that I can then
use to continue the next thing I did is
I built a reference implementation of a
CPU that means I have built something
that in just pure python code emulates
the CPU so you can see right here I have
constants which are usually defined at
the beginning of the program I have
registers and I have memory and these
I'm kind of cheating a little bit right
here see usually things are way more
compc complicated than I'm doing this
right now but whenever possible I'm just
kind of storing values in the registers
and not pointers to them and then I have
to trick around a bit when it comes to
arrays and things like this in any case
I'm emulating a CPU right here with
python and the idea is just that I need
to make sure that my whole parsing setup
works and so you can see right here I am
going through the operations and I'm
kind of implementing them with python
addition easy
multiplication that's that array lookup
certainly and all of these types of
things are just implemented in terms of
pure python code we can actually run
this right now so if I actually go back
here and I use the reference uh
implementation you can
see bisbas in all its glory and um I
hope that's correct at least it probably
is it probably is so this gives me
confidence that my whole parsing and and
so on is is correct and it obviously
runs way faster because I'm just kind of
emulating a CPU in Python however what I
did next was Will shock you so next I
implemented a VM based on GPT now in
this VM I'm still managing the registers
myself so the registers are just going
to be a a dict um that I manage however
uh now every single operation in here is
a prompt for example
if I need to get something from
registers what I'll do is I'll send the
prompt look at the registers and then
I'll send the full registers and I'll
say now get me the value of a certain
index in the register it's up to GPT to
look up the correct thing in that deck
and give it back to me I have addition
prompts I have remainder prompts I have
comparison prompts as you can see right
here even system prompts you're a very
keen Observer
all right let's dive into this let's
look at this block right here uh block
with the label number six so the first
thing it does is it actually loads uh
from the pointer number two in the
registers uh into a value into number
seven so into register 7 these are
abstract registers for now but bear with
me um we see right here that in the
debug log this is from the program uh
code what we need to do this is my
parsing of this line now I sent this to
GPT I say look at these registers right
here so I have registers number one is
zero number two is zero and so on these
are registers that that I manag but I
just sent them to GPT as a string and
tell it get me the value of number two
so this corresponds to this line right
here in the in the code and the system
correctly says that's zero okay so the
next thing is we need to assign this to
the register zero all right um assigning
in this VM is simply me putting it into
the registers however in a later
iteration which I'll show you later even
that is done by GPT so the next thing is
we want to compute the remainder of the
register number seven where we just
stored something with the number three
all right so the first thing we need to
do is we need to read from the registers
so I'm again going to send the registers
to GPT and they get me the value of
register number 7 it says that's zero
that is correct that is indeed zero as
you can see right here then I let it
compute the remainder so get the
remainder value of 0 / 3 again it says 0
that's correct assign that to number
eight that's up here in the code and
then we'll compare the next instruction
is a comparison an integer comparison
between 8 and zero
again we look at the registers we get
the value of number eight it says
correctly that's zero and we execute the
comparison operation are Z and Z equal
you're a very keen Observer and we get
the answer yes so let's assign that to
register number n no we can't control
what GPT says it could be like yes
that's true or anything like this
whatever it says we'll just store it
into the register now further down we're
going to do a conditional jump so look
at the registers get me the Val of
number nine and I have a bit of a
truthiness conversion right here to be a
bit robust and I do a branching jump
right here but you can see that for
given instruction right here there's
either going to be one or even multiple
GP uh sorry GPT instructions that go
along with it and thereby this is truly
the world's most expensive and most
faulty probably CPU so let me show you a
bit of a different program right here
and it's called snake and if I execute
this on a uh on this you can see it's a
very basic form of snake so I can move
the little o around until it kind of
eats the uh eats the the star you can
see it works and if I eat it I actually
win it's not a complicated program but
it's quite a bit more complicated than
the fs buuz program as you can see right
here but I didn't just Implement FSB
right we have a full we have a fully
fledged compiler from anyc program to G
to running it on GPT and that's exciting
so all we need to do you know mod
modular sum UPS I haven't implemented
all we need to do is we need to run this
through llvm get the intermediate
representation and then run it through
my parser and then we can fully play
Snake on GPT and how awesome is that who
before has played Snake on
GPT I know I know the next iteration is
Doom but so if I run this now this is
going to go and go and go you can see
how the registers get slowly filled up
with values coming back from gbt and uh
we're doing comparisons we're doing all
kinds of math we're doing additions and
remainders and you can see it kind of
screwing up uh the answer is one is here
in the registers instead of just the
number one and that will flow into next
prompts and so on so this is an
extremely faulty system it's extremely
inefficient it's extremely wasteful like
we're using the world's most powerful
language models um but we're doing it in
service of playing snake and I think if
anything if anything that's a cause
that's worth it in fact it's going to
take about 600 instructions until I can
do the first input in this program
conditioned on it never failing because
it will just randomly decide that now
the number two is actually greater than
the number 30 um and oh look here it it
made an array that's certainly good I'm
pretty sure that's good um yeah so
you'll see it has a few faults and it
has a few uh sharp corners but you know
in general it kind of works
and not only that but I've gone further
than
this see not only have I made a basic VM
that just executes the instructions I
have also made one that even manages the
registers itself so instead of the
registers being a dict the registers are
not just a string that I initialize with
an empty dict but it has to do all of
the stuff by itself and as an extension
of that I've implemented this beauty
right here so I call it Chad GP TVM and
the prompt is is kind of always the same
it's look bro I know you love to talk
but I really just need the answer please
don't explain your you have to I'm
really not good at prompting uh but get
from registers is implemented like this
bro look at these rad registers bro for
real just tell me the value of register
something addition is implemented as yo
what's the s of this and
that bro for real do you know how
remainders and stuff works I really need
the remainder value of that my man you
mag good at
multiplication and you know this is it's
it's a beauty to watch this work so so
let's do that I can't I literally can't
wait
anymore all right this is now
considerably slower because not only am
I asking it for you know any particular
uh register value but I always send the
full state of the registers and I get
back the full state of the registers now
nothing constrains it to uh make a dick
and send me back a dick it could send me
back whatever it wants sometimes
actually it does that sometimes uh it
just kind of sends back something else
um it just it just puts some text around
it or gives me some friendly comments so
you see uh my main man I need you to
store the value zero in register 9 and
um these are the current registers and
it gives me the the result again has
nine here but also nine here so um it
just kind of doubled up the registers
right here and um yeah that's that's
certainly not good so I guess register 2
here kind of holds another dick with the
registers that's kind of closed here so
you know like this CPU it might need
some
work watch out tsmc we're coming we're
coming for you uh you will not be able
to compete right here Nvidia Nvidia
stock goes goes this is not Financial
advice Nvidia stock boom tsmc stock boom
Chad GPT stock through the roof this
just shows if you set yourself a goal
you can achieve anything you want with
that being said uh the code here is on
get up
do with it whatever you want uh it's a
giant waste of money and time but you
know you can play Snake and what else is
there that was it for me thank you very
much I'll see you around
[Music]
bye-bye